death will come to all of us especially  soldiers you give your life away so  others will live and take life where  only God can give it  you  what the hell are they doing here and  got their hands on a compound that kills  humans and nothing else medical says  they've never seen anything like it  Conrad's found out on the grill man  haven't they it's time to take the war  to them the boat move sent a team in  destroy the stuff I hear you need a ship  only work better alone shouldn't fear me  I'm just one man one man that was a  Spartan ready to go to hell colonel  never thought we'd set foot on a halo  wreck  are we really doing this stay on mission  something what the hell are they  we will not go out like this  my question to you commander lock how  will you lead and for what  you  you